everything that happened yesterday that
means nothing
[Applause]
when you're 19 and you can spend seven
full years learning your craft meeting
people that are mentors being patient
and you wake up and you're 26 years old
you have your entire life in front of
you and you've done great foundational
work to go on of them be successful I
just don't get it I don't get why people
think at 18 20 to 30 that they have to
have their life figured out when they
live to 90 and aunties any quick piece
of advice it's patience tonight it's
patience it's you can't be lost in life
when you're this young you actually have
everything figured out eighteen or
twenty percent into your life absolutely
not not more importantly than that your
life evolved changes as you get older
too many kids don't take advantage of
time they're in such a rush to find it
or be doing it that they don't take
advantage of the thing they have
figuring everything out is a forever
game have you figured out how awesome
you're gonna be as a grandma when you're
still not a grandma whether it's your
parents or yourself or people
everybody's trying to prove something so
early because the pressures of society
the pressures of your siblings and most
of all the pressures of your parents so
many of you are scared to fail because
your dad's gonna make you feel bad about
it and I'm I've empathy for that that
sucks I'm very fascinated by negative
energy that is not cut out of all you
need to put your [ __ ] ear pods in
or this ideological thing that the media
or culture has put in your head of what
you're supposed to be or how you're
supposed to roll or what's supposed to
be happening at this point it's
ludicrous
you're not lost in life they're just
early in the process you just don't need
90 year olds that talk about how pomp
they are that they made an extra hundred
thousand dollars like they don't exist
they talk about regret I wish I did
literally inevitably I do this I wish as
the opening line the judgment you put on
yourself that is actually being
fabricated by outside forces is to me
the thing that I'm trying to
fundamentally broke that breakdown just
fundamentally trying to break it down
everybody's judging themselves way too
early you can literally do nothing for
next eight years
and be a child time is your asset the
one thing a 20 year old has over me is
20 [ __ ] years but you don't think
that because when you're 20 - you don't
think 31 is young maybe there's another
view yeah I mean that's you know it's oh
wait everybody's got strengths and
weaknesses what what a 60 year old has
is experienced but doesn't have time
what youth has is time you can literally
do four different things over the next
two years six months at a time to figure
out everything that you think you might
like you should try to do but that's not
what people tell you to do
100% what I would do is gather as many
experiences as possible go and travel
and learn go and start that business
that you've always wanted hook up with
those three teammates and start that
band you've always wanted this is the
time to be massively risk massively risk
oriented pick something if I can do it
you're [ __ ] young kid you do all 19
things but if you're under 30 to 33 and
you're devastated that you don't have
your life figured out you're just
looking at the game completely wrong
take a breath take a [ __ ] breath and
so that's what I'm trying to tell people
it's what you don't do that squeeze with
you later on the reason you're not
winning and doing what you want is
somebody's opinion somebody's opinion of
you matters more to you then you're a
pain
it's very true
[Music]